the host of National Public Radio's a
Prairie Home Companion for 13 years I'd
like to welcome my fellow Club members
and their guests in the audience today
as well as those of you who are
listening to this program over one of
the more than 350 national public radio
stations are watching on one of the 2600
cable systems affiliated with c-span the
cable satellite Public Affairs Network
now before going any further I'd like to
remind our members of some coming
lunches our future speakers include Sir
David Wilson the governor of Hong Kong
tomorrow a Republican presidential
nomination contender L Haig the day
after tomorrow the chairman of the
Navajo Nation Peter McDonald on October
27 author share height on October 28
television commentator David frost on
November 3rd Commerce Secretary William
Verity who had a very interesting first
day in office yesterday on November 10
an opera star Beverly Sills will be here
on November 18 in her capacity as the
1988 national chairman of the March of
Dimes ok now I'd like to remind those of
you in the audience that if you have any
questions for our speakers today and
apparently about 60 of you already know
just write them on the cards and hand
them in if you want a little clue as to
have a chance to have yours be one of
those selected of the first 65 I would
say approximately 63 are about Lake
Wobegon so if we get some on other
topics as well you got a good shot in it
now I'd like to introduce the guests at
the head table and I ask our guests to
please stand briefly while their names
are read and I also ask the audience to
withhold your applause until I've read
all the names we'll start on my left
with Bob Menzies heimer
of USA Today Phil galley bureau chief of
the st. Petersburg Times Richard Moe the
former chief of staff for Vice President
Walter Mondale a Minnesotan and a
campaign junkie and
attorney sue Duquette producer of
Washington we can review Dave Hess of
knight-ridder newspapers a former pres
club president Bill Klein of Media
general newspapers the chairman of the
Press Club speakers committee bents COO
who is Minister councilor for press and
information at the Embassy of Denmark
Tom Bruce itis bureau chief of the
Cleveland Plain Dealer Ellen Masson
prasena of Canadian Broadcasting Dan
Devaney vice president and general
manager of WTAE FM 91 and Diane Rehm of
wamu 88.5 FM Tom de Frank of Newsweek
magazine
now I know everybody's wondering why the
stock market dropped five hundred points
yesterday and then began to go back up
this morning and then down again as it
does and to explain all that we've
invited a special luncheon speaker
his name is Garrison Keillor I am a
collector and my wife's a thrower away
and I'd like to show you an incident in
an instance of how I triumph this is the
Thursday October 24 1929 edition of the
Brooklyn daily eagle which has Wall
Street in panic as stocks crash the
headlines similar to those that appeared
in this morning's paper comes in a
genuine reproduction of that edition of
the Brooklyn daily eagle which I bought
about a month ago presciently enough in
the st. Louis Airport and one of the
things that makes a reproduction
interesting is it shows you not just the
front page headline but it shows you the
back pages as well and we learned that
on the same day that that day that we
were hearing about that the stock market
was crashing if we turn to the back page
of the paper we'll see a story called
parents plan luncheon extensive
preparations have been completed by the
Executive Committee of the Parents
Association of PS 217 for a luncheon and
bridge Saturday at Auctions restaurant
in Church Avenue to celebrate the
addition of a 7a grade to their school
mrs. M Mandal is chairman of the affair
superintendent James J Reynolds and mrs.
Mel Neera cybermen principal will be
guests of honor and I think one of the
reasons why those of us in journalism so
much have become involved in the
audience in reading and in listening
audience for Garrison Keillor is
precisely because we know that a
newspaper and life are a lot more than
just the front page when Garrison
Keillor spoke here at the club last year
it was being reported that he was in the
middle of one of those life crises he
was too famous and his weekly radio show
a Prairie Home Companion had four
million devoted listeners
and his book late Lake Wobegon days was
a best-seller and he couldn't walk down
the street in st. Paul Minnesota without
being stopped and treated like a
celebrity and for a man who treasures
his shyness it was unbearable or so the
story goes and mr. Keeler found a
solution he married his long-lost
highschool sweetheart and he flew off
with his family to her native Denmark
no more powder milk biscuits and no more
quiet weeks in Lake Wobegon he would
learn how to farm and he wouldn't be
famous
he'd be happy and in fact his days in
Copenhagen were full he took language
lessons and he got his teeth fixed
[Music]
sometimes he combined the two activities
mastering the Danish words for can you
feel pain well I gave us all a taste of
pain at the end of the last school year
when his show went off the air here in
Washington on the station I listened to
a Prairie Home Companion comes on just
before Mary cliff she plays folk music
records and conducts folk music
interviews every Saturday night starting
at 8:00 ending at 1:00 a.m. mostly its
old favorites if I had a hammer or sweet
Molly Malone singing about cockles and
mussels alive alive all but in another
life I think Mary Cliff used to teach
fifth grade because every once in a
while she plays some folk music you
never heard of before and I imagine she
thinks it's good for us and she's
stretching our young minds
and one of those times she played some
music called klezmer music by a
clarinetist named Yuri fide Minh and
it's a kind of a wild gypsy like music
that used to be played in middle Europe
but Jewish weddings and he plays it on a
clarinet and it's a bold beautiful clear
tone and it's really memorable my wife
and I got into the habit that whenever
we would hear one of his records on her
show the one who was in the room would
call the other one to come on in and
listen to this we never actually called
in a request that it were like a little
too shy but one day char and I saw in
the paper that URI fight Minh was going
to play out of the barns of Wolf Trap on
Saturday night at 8 p.m. and that's
about a half hour drive from our house
so we got reservations over the phone
and we left the house about 7:15 p.m.
and of course that's about the time that
on the car radio Garrison Keillor starts
his monologue so traffic was light and
the night was clear it was winter night
and we had hardly any red lights and we
zipped right along and we arrived at the
parking lot
long before schedule and garrison story
was still going on on the radio and it
wasn't one of those easy stories either
it was one of those Lake Wobegon stories
where you aren't sure how it's going to
come out so we parked the car and we sat
in it and we listened you we turned off
the ignition so we weren't going to
asphyxiate ourselves but you turned it
on back half way and you can hear the
radio and finally this story ended and
we heard those magic words they were
sitting in that parking lot surrounded
by all those dark cars and we're hearing
the words where all the women are strong
and all the men are good-looking and all
the children above average so I opened
the door on my side of the car and I got
out and I slammed it shut and was a funk
and then all across the parking lot I
heard
and I thought my god somebody else
listens to him too and you know before
that when people ask me where I was from
I used to say I live in Washington and
now when they asked me where it from I
told Niles Michigan it's my hometown you
see I come from the Midwest Garrison
Keillor was born in Minnesota which is
the second best part of the Midwest
Minnesota in fact is the corruption of
an Indian word meaning Michigan and
we're all very proud of how well
Minnesota has done in recent years and
those of us that cheer for the Detroit
Tigers don't feel one bit of envy or
bitterness towards the Minnesota Twins
just because they're in the World Series
and I mean really it's their turn
and mr. minister we feel the same way
about Denmark maybe right now Denmark
needs Garrison Keillor or maybe he needs
them and that's okay too
as long as there are days like today
when the stock market begins to recover
from its drop of 500 points and the
stories in the back of the paper are
rather reassuring when you compare them
to the stories in the front of the paper
and Garrison Keillor drops by to say
hello to some of his folks back home
members and guests please join me in
welcoming the author of leaving home
mr. Garrison Keillor
[Applause]
thank you very much I appreciate that if
I'm responsible for for getting the
press minister of Denmark up to the head
table here I'm proud of myself and feel
that I've accomplished something even
before I start in here today I doubt
that when general Hague is your speaker
that the Danish Embassy will be
represented up as a head table hope that
I hope that he makes full use of our
facilities up here and and enjoys it for
all it's worth it's so lovely to be here
with you even on the day after such a
catastrophic event which we we think is
catastrophic but we're not sure and a
lot of people in this room are the ones
who are supposed to be explaining this
to the American people
I don't know how to explain it I never
knew that the that the Dow Jones average
was above 500 so it could
so it could fall that far without going
through the floor but it's sobering to
to walk over to the Press Club and see
the boxes with the two New York tabloids
down on the street the post and the
Daily News and both of them using Second
Coming type face
[Music]
one of them says one of them says panic
and the other one says says a crisis the
people who aren't really affected much
by that I guess are the people back
where I come from Minnesota where I have
now left where people the a week or so
ago rose several thousand points each
one of them and it would take more than
a stock market drop to bring them down
home of the Minnesota Twins it's a
strange thing to stand here to be here
with you and to know that all of that is
going on back home strange thing to have
spent your adult life rooting for a team
and then the very day that you closed on
your house and get in your car that same
night they clinched the Western Division
of the American League
[Music]
just when you get outside of the radio
signal they do this and get into the
World Series we had been together the
Minnesota Twins and I for 20-some years
and many of those years were not that
bad
and to have them get into the series now
it's like it's like moments after the
divorce your ex-wife says she has found
somebody and is ecstatically happy and
in love and you're glad that it's
happened to her of course you're glad
for her but you wish it had happened
while you were still there
[Music]
especially those of us who grew up in
Minnesota and we are different a
different kind of baseball fan than than
other people in New York for example
where people who follow the Mets and the
Yankees feel that triumph is due them is
coming to them demanded and expected in
Minnesota we tend to be quiet fans
because we believe that whatever happens
is probably our fault
always sit at a Twins game and think
about the sins in your life that made it
necessary for God to do this to these
for these fine young men so to have them
be so successful within hours after I
left home is is is a sad experience it's
it's like it's like leaving a quiet
dinner party and the host and the
hostess beg you to stay longer but you
have to leave and then you go out to the
parking lot and open your car door and
just about then you hear voices raising
inside the house and the Dvorak comes
off the stereo and they put on the James
Brown whoops and cries
the party takes off just when you leave
but we we were brought up to believe
that eventually our luck would change we
weren't sure when we're not sure that it
has in Lake Wobegon where I come from
people are taking a wait-and-see
attitude towards it waiting for the tide
to turn against us and waiting for the
grasshoppers to blacken the skies fly in
and eat the artificial turf waiting for
things to turn wrong as we deserve for
them to then after the twins win the
series waiting 60 or 90 days for a
lawsuit and sometime sometime around
Christmas maybe starting to believe that
that we really had that that terrific
team we believe that all things come to
those who wait I was brought up to
believe and evidently it is true and I
just didn't wait quite long enough but
that for twins fans as for Democrats as
for investors in the stock market it'll
all come round again if you just stand
in one place and wait for it to and that
is true I guess for us Democrats too
it's true back in 1980 I believe that
Ronald Reagan could not be elected
president of the United States and in
1984 I believe that Walter Mondale could
beat him
and now as 1988 approaches I believe
that Ronald Reagan cannot be elected to
a third term
[Music]
eventually you eventually you you win
you just have to just have to wait for
the rest of them to leave somebody asked
me downstairs if if I was in Washington
to promote my new book which kind of
makes me sad for people to I think that
a man has other motives for coming to
Washington going around meeting meeting
with people kind of like the press to be
skeptical like that and to look for
hidden hidden motives what a person does
I I travel around to be helpful I'm not
here to promote myself I'm a Christian
we don't we don't do that as reporters
find out when they when they talk to me
I am getting together this afternoon
with several people whom I understand
worked for a newspaper and and
television but usually when reporters
sit down with me we talk about things
for a while and then we start talking
about them because I'm here to be
helpful
usually we spend most of the hour
talking about them and and some of their
problems and and the treatment and how
it worked and end their marriage and the
last car before this one that they honed
and how what a good runner it was and
how they wish they'd hung on to it to
their mortgage and the terms of it and
what they would have gotten if they just
waited another year or so the principle
of the Christian promotion is back in
the book of Proverbs where Solomon says
let another man praise thee and not
thine own lips so
when you travel around as a as a sort of
retiring celebrity you you you find out
a great deal about the press maybe more
than is sometimes good for you to know
those of you who are here and covering
this and who are wondering when I would
get to the body of my remarks
I have them I have written out for you
actually a story here that you could
file on this event saving you the time
of having to organize this yourself you
have tape recorders you're welcome to
turn them on at this point you're
welcome to use any of this if you want
my headline is I don't know if this fits
if you want a something full-page this
might not be a long enough headline here
but American needs more time off says
beloved writer
[Applause]
former American radio Idol Garrison
Keillor says that American men and women
work quote to gall-darn heart unquote
and that Congress should attack the
problem of workaholism by passing a
national vacation law similar to that in
effect in Denmark Keeler whose wife is
Danish and who spent the summer in the
tiny Scandinavian Kingdom just north of
Germany spoke Tuesday before a capacity
audience at times almost enthusiastic at
the August National Press Club in
Washington DC our nation's capital which
was laid out by the French engineer
Lockhart thus delaying the author's
arrival
[Music]
[Applause]
second paragraph quote we've carried the
work ethic farther than God ever
intended and he must look down in sorrow
at a nation so obsessed with
productivity materialism and career
status and power that its citizens race
pell-mell through life impervious to the
beauty of the natural world
the sweetness of fellowship the joys of
idleness the fine arts of fishing and
baseball and slow talk of slow cooking
and long summer evenings on the porch
sipping good whiskey telling long lives
close quote
said the youthful and strangely
attractive 45 year old author of the
popular Lake Wobegon days and now of the
knot on brilliant leaving home newly
published by Viking press at a sensible
low price of 1895 quote Ronald Reagan
has thankfully released us from the
institution of the workaholic presidency
and proven that when the chief knocks
off it doesn't [ __ ] the government
but often improves it
a 36-hour presidential week and five to
eight weeks of vacation a year are what
this country need more of he said he
called on candidates of both parties to
join him in supporting legislation
giving every American the right and
obligation to take five weeks of
vacation every year just as in Denmark
our partner in NATO
quote the principle of vacation of the
god-given right to rest such as the
almighty decreed to the children of
Israel is above and beyond creed or
partisanship close quote he said in his
rich baritone voice as the normally
reserved journalists sighed and chuckled
and dabbed at tears of mirth and
gratitude quote we owe it to ourselves
as a gift we are a good people I never
met an American voter or book buyer whom
I didn't like we ought to do this as a
symbol of our national self-acceptance
third draft Keeler's warm green eyes
flickered with amusement as his strong
hands hens that obviously had known hard
manual labour gripped the lectern his
features were strong and simple a gift
of his anglo-scottish ancestry dating
back to colonial days in America far
from patrician in style however he
mingled easily with the press many of
whom are Catholic or Jewish
some of whom had foreign or regional
accents while declining comment on his
presidential plans the gentle satirist
has scheduled a foreign policy
fact-finding trip to Israel Sweden Japan
England and the Soviet Union where he
will meet with premier Gorbachev a close
friend from all boyscout world Jamboree
days and at all relaxed father of for a
devoted son who writes to his elderly
parents once a week without fail and
phones on holidays and birthdays a
church-going man known for hundreds of
little charitable deeds that he wishes
to remain anonymous and unsung killer
while pooh-poohing persistent rumors of
a presidential attempt saying it's much
too late and I can't see subjecting my
family to the glare of the public eye
and besides I can't afford to run
because big interest groups know I'm not
for sale no time know how close quote
nevertheless sounded almost like a
candidate at times particularly when he
admitted to three instances of impure
thoughts as a youth and said he was
briefly addicted to over-the-counter
drugs but is now completely milk of
magnesia free
he also sounded a presidential note when
he repeatedly used the phrase the new
civilization each time pounding his
right fist into his left palm and
establishing solid eye contact with
cameras in the back of the room and his
hair had more body and more lustrous
tone his complexion was clearer than
those in the room had seen before and
his smile was not only white but
dazzling white he smelled of a rich
Midwestern fragrance gentle but
masculine he promised that the National
five-week vacation law would be a
cornerstone of the new civilization and
said the law would cover not only
working people but also unemployed and
the impoverished it is hard work being
poor and homeless he said poverty is not
for the timid they deserve a break to
Keillor known as a sensitive man
appeared close to tears at one point
while describing a two-week vacation
that he took on Northwest Airlines once
[Music]
[Laughter]
but he regained his composure and at the
conclusion of the address members of the
press who are normally reserved rose as
one and had to be restrained though from
what was not immediately apparent the
book is available at good bookstores
everywhere the office
you're awfully nice and and it's lovely
to come here and break my retirement
with you it's a frightening thing to get
up in front of a microphone and be on
radio and talk to a roomful of people
after months of not doing months in
another country and Denmark where if an
American can say good morning and thank
you and where is the railway station
they they think that you just brilliant
especially your mother-in-law does I've
thought of you often during the summer I
have missed you far more than you ever
could have missed me and now I would
like to get on to your questions gosh I
just looking down here at some of them
how many of you in this room let me ask
you a question how many of you in this
room believe that honesty is always the
best policy how many of you believe that
honesty is is sometimes
a good strategy all right I'll take that
in to take that into consideration
are you gonna read these or do I get to
take my choice he says you left home
seeking anonymity now you are back what
did you gain from the experience well
I'm not sure that I'm back I left behind
an apartment in Copenhagen and a lot of
people there whom I miss and a language
that that I have just I have just begun
to try to scale you can't stay away from
Danish very long if you are serious
about learning it anybody who is married
to a Danish woman had better try to
learn it and even now I feel my language
slipping away from me mascara
patelliday pedantically perhaps I should
tell you this in Danish Misha Misha
Taylor dansk if I speak Danish to the
mosque a Caniggia
or the Mawson you may not think it is
humorous men
dokkan dokkan eager see singapore took
an egg there Singapore they egg am
awesome but you could not say for sure
that it wasn't funny
the people who laughed at that the
hardest are the Danes who are yes do you
miss your radio show do you expect to do
another well I don't expect I don't
expect very much I've been living in New
York for the last couple of weeks and
New York teaches you that not to not to
expect anything in particular from each
given day but to sort of ride out
whatever happens but I miss it I miss it
terribly I could not find any any work
in Denmark that I was the least bit
useful that except for washing dishes as
we see these headlines in the paper we
start to think about other career skills
that we may have been washing dishes is
is one of mine I put myself through a
part of college washing dishes which is
why I do it so seldom now that I'm
married because I'm a professional and I
can handle large amounts of them but to
do just a few doesn't really interest me
that much
[Music]
same reason the journalists don't write
letters but I did dishes in Denmark and
our sink you stand at the sink and wash
dishes and the first thing that I missed
was that the person who was standing
next to me and drying the dishes was
Danish and so did not know the words to
the same songs that I know and that I
used to sing with my sister when I did
dishes that's what I miss about the
radio is singing songs with people who
know the words but as I stood there and
I looked we have a cupboard you look
directly into the cupboard when you
stand at the sink and wash we've got a
slump a little bit if you're a tall
person and that brings your face forward
and there's a cupboard right there and
when the doors are open you can see the
cups and the saucers in the front but in
the back it's dark I often imagined you
sitting in the back of my cupboard and
and I spoke to you sometimes this timer
in in English
spoke directly in past the salt shakers
you don't want to wait here for what
sounds like a definite sort of a
conclusion
[Music]
I tend to trail off on these
this questioner wants to know if you
would please announce and pronounce
slowly your new address and phone number
for those of us who want to contact you
after this luncheon you made in Denmark
the Danish address I'm not sure you
could pronounce it or know how to spell
it but Denmark is a small country so you
just ask anybody that you meet over
there and they can they can give you
directions exactly Washingtonian wants
to know do you and your fellow
Minnesotans still feel a collective
guilt for stealing our baseball team
well I don't think you did an awful lot
with that baseball team the Washington
Senators the old senators not the more
recent ones you it became legendary team
but for the wrong reasons as it became a
legendary loser like the Chicago Cubs
that's what the Minnesota Twins are
supposed to be saving us from this this
week and next is from getting into
national mythology in a way that we'd
like to avoid after four years of the
Vikings being in the Superbowl and
Hubert Humphrey losing so narrowly in
1968 and Walter Mondale losing in 1984 I
think one more and we go into the record
books
we'd like to avoid that if we can in
Minnesota we have had many opportunities
in the last couple of decades to learn
that second place doesn't taste like
anything at all in particular so we'll
see most of us know how the twins are
doing these days but what about the
whippets
well the weapon's season ended earlier
than the twins yet it it always ends
around Labor Day people that age as some
of the whippets do not like to do
strenuous activities outdoors when it's
cool there were there were there were
members of the whippets who would have
been glad to see the season end even
before Labor Day because we believe in
hoping for next year but you can only do
that when the season is open did anyone
from Lake Wobegon organized a trip to
st. Louis for tonight's World Series
game are they down in st. Louis tonight
all right
no no no st. Louis see it's odd they're
being wrong the Mississippi River the
same as we are and everything but but I
don't know anybody in Minnesota who's
been to st. Louis
it's just not it's not it's not a city
that's closely tied to us by commerce or
or culture or anything it's it's a it's
a blank to me I can't remember the last
time I was there trying to remember and
I can't Ken Bob's Bank survived the
stock market plunge Bob's is never
invested heavily in anything anything
that you couldn't personally visit in
about a half
Bob does not believe in in sending money
by mail that money is a personal thing
to Bob and his bank they may not pay
high interest rates but it'll be there
when you need it provided you have a
good explanation for why you want
[Music]
I think the terrifying thing about this
about this stock market crash or
whatever you want to call it is is is
the idea that this could all be going on
between computers with human beings
hardly involved at all that that these
vast banks of computers all over the
country using the phone lines are
battling each other for for stocks and
and that we have no we have no part in
this evidently you find that shocking
too
as the recent news about the private
life of television ministers had any
impact on the gospel birds well the
gospel birds are a traveling troupe of
of Christian performers who go around
and performant churches in small towns
that have attendance problems for the
midweek services in larger cities
they've given up the midweek service
years and years ago but in Lake Wobegon
they still have hopes of bringing people
out to sit in church on a Wednesday
night the gospel birds I think are as
yet untouched by by scandal it's an
impressive troupe
little parakeets and parrots and pigeons
and the birds that reenact favorite
stories from the Old Testament in in
costume taken around by the Lundin was a
lovely lovely couple and I wish that I
had written a story about them that
there was really you faithful to them
such sweet people that's what happens
see when you make reference here to a
story that I've told you in the past I
I've had three months off two more than
that five months to sit and contemplate
all of these people whom I've told
stories about the London's and the
gospel birds and and all the other
people and a storyteller has to has to
keep working if you ever stop and think
about what you've done just feel such
guilt
not having done better by him by these
people so do you have another question
about Lake Wobegon that I can this one
starts with this angling modifier it
says being a normal guy explain to me
how to deal with so many New Yorkers and
retain your normalcy well I think you
have to forget about normalcy if you are
living in New York there are a lot of
there are a lot of things that our
mothers taught us to do to be nice
polite people you have to put those away
when you're in New York to go through
life in New York without ever raising
your voice speaking in a sharp manner to
to another person without pushing
without to go through life in New York
with the principle of taking turns
it's another another piece of our of our
raising that hangs around our necks
like a millstone when we get in a big
city Lutheran's who have moved away from
Minnesota to big cities who who sit half
the evening on entrance ramps of
freeways just wait
you have to put those things aside too
otherwise you are giving up you're
giving up all of your weapons you're
throwing yourself on on their mercy and
I'm not sure I'm not sure if their mercy
is anything I'd want to count on for
long run by like New York I Love New
York
it's an exciting city
I've always been thrilled by it since I
was a little kid
those old radio shows I listened to his
boy came from New York New York was the
first place I traveled as as a boy my
dad took me there in 1953 and I got to
see the Brooklyn Dodgers play at Ebbets
Field see Coney Island I never forgot it
especially because he didn't really want
to take me but he did and it's the the
trip of my life was that trip that I
took when I was 11 years old to the big
city
it's the trip against which all other
trips are compared I could tell you
everything about that trip where we
stayed and almost everything that we did
so if you have them if you have 11 or 12
year old kids you keep that in mind
whatever you do for them may likely turn
out to be permanent and memorable
other people in Minnesota other people
in Lake Wobegon they kind of they kind
of looked to California as the place to
go if things did not work out that may
be true
I look to I look to New York as the
place to go if everything worked out
right
would you ever write a play
well I've threatened to I've threatened
to in the past but the people who I try
to write about I'm not sure that there
are there are actors and actresses who
can portray them like there's a peculiar
dialect that these people have that that
they don't teach in drama school it's
kind of its kind of a murmuring dialect
trailing off at the end of sentences and
and one thing in particular that we do
in Lake Wobegon that I don't think you
could do on a stages is uttering some of
your some of your most important lines
while you're going into the next room so
that the last part of it disappears
entirely be difficult to do on a stage
you have this week's stock market
developments help business at the
fearmonger shop well well is this the
worst that can happen we don't know that
I don't think it's quite gotten to to
that point yet but of course I haven't I
haven't looked at the afternoon paper
yet is there an afternoon paper
several people wanted to know if there's
a song that you would like to sing with
us today really that's awfully sweet of
you to think of that of course of course
they're over in Denmark a country that I
have been trying to figure out and and a
country that I that I felt so much more
certain of my opinions about it the
first week I was there than I did
a month later I felt after a week in
Denmark I felt I could write a book
about it and then after about a month or
so I thought I could write a magazine
article about it and now I'd be
satisfied to say three true things about
that country but one thing I say for
sure is that Danes love occasions like
this know how to throw a party know how
to have a good time if this were in
Denmark this chicken that we ate today
would have been a little bit different
and there would have been more than two
speakers all Danes insist on their right
to speak at a banquet like this it would
have gone on for hours we would have had
1215 different speakers and we would all
have sung a song if this were Denmark do
you know tell me why
that's about where C is right where I'm
humming right there I feel she was kind
of a faint murmuring sound there tried
that C again and and you did that better
than you could have been fight Union now
the women have to just go up about two
steps together the harmony part
[Music]
okay remember that top part the women
get to sing that lovely high harmony
part that descant
heart that you all known tell me why the
Ivy twins I forget the words this song
tell me why the stars do shine tell me
why the sky is so blue and I will tell
you why I have to say
[Music]
[Music]
the skies just take a special verse here
for the Minnesota Twins take me out too
take me
where
is the crowd buy me some peanuts and
[Music]
don't carry
your women have to sing that high
harmony part you're the beauty of this
song just as you are in real life you're
the beauty in the meaning of this song
if you give up your part there's no
reason to sing it the what's the what's
the last verse because God
the stars
the
[Music]
the sky
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
and in addition to a certificate of
appreciation I'd like to present you
with the National Press Club pen which
according to the accompanying material
is a space pen that will write
underwater over Greece at temperatures
of minus 50 degrees to over plus 400
degrees Fahrenheit and 250,000 miles
into space and I'd like to thank you
very much and ask you a question that we
must ask of all speakers this year
because of our responsibilities of the
club if elected how frequently will you
hold news conferences
[Laughter]
I tell you if elected if elected I will
serve and and if elected I will hold
news conferences more often than you
would like you've been watching an
address of the National Press Club by
author and radio humorist Garrison
Keillor this reminder c-span will air a
National Press Club address Sunday
morning by Sir David Wilson the governor
of Hong Kong that's at 7:00 a.m. Eastern
time for Pacific
[Music]